[Music]
so the key question no one doubts that
people who come to counseling or receive
psychiatric services are in great
distress they may be extremely confused
and low in mood has serious relationship
difficulties or disabling panic attacks
and so on
sometimes they're tormented by hostile
voices or have terrifying mood swings
but are they suffering from medical
illnesses that need diagnosing or do we
need completely different ways of
understanding their distress which are
not based on diagnosis and if so what
those might those ways be so to be
really really clear the distress is real
there's a lot of muddled thinking about
this isn't the distress is real the
explanations are up for question two
important messages few people can afford
to give up diagnosis entirely we live in
a diagnostically based system it is
needed or some something rather similar
is needed for access to benefit services
and so on but people may decide they do
not wish to define themselves and their
problems in this way you may decide I do
not want to take on the belief that I am
suffering from schizophrenia or bipolar
disorder or pus and how they disorder
all major depressive disorder or any of
that stuff and you do not want to take
on the identity of someone who is
mentally ill which is not a highly
valued identity and comes with many many
significant disadvantages and that
should be up to you you can only make
that choice if you're clear about the
arguments okay but these are very
complex discussions I hope you don't
waste as much time on Twitter as I do
but you can see that it's almost
impossible to raise these questions at
all without being accused as I have on
many many occasions of silencing and
vilifying and attacking service users
and shaming people for taking pills and
all the rest of it it's like and the
underlying message is quite disturbing I
think from some people that we are not
allowed to have these discussions well I
think we have to have these discussions
many times I've been told how device if
it is to have these discussions the most
important discussions that we need to
have our devices by their nature you
know think about abortion and Ireland
you know we have to have these
discussions
but as a society this is a quote from my
book we seem to find it hard to find a
middle ground between you have a
physical illness and therefore your
distress is real and known is to blame
for it and your difficulties are
imaginary and/or your or someone else's
fault and you ought to pull yourself
together are you familiar with that kind
of dichotomy as soon as they ask
questions it's like you're blaming
people undermining them telling to pull
themselves together this is sometimes
called the brain or blame trap
if it's not my brain then I or someone
else must be to blame and we will
further uncomfortable that in America
they call it chemistry or character and
my question is could there be a middle
ground a ground which is about
understanding how people got to the
situations that they're in which doesn't
involve blame but doesn't simply
attribute it to some hypothesized but
never evidenced malfunction in their
brains or whatever a lot of these
arguments came to the head came to our
head with the publication of dsm-5 in
May 2013 most of you will know that DSM
the Diagnostic and Statistical Manual of
Mental Disorders is the sometimes called
the Bible that lists all our 400 or more
ways in which we can apparently be
mentally ill or disordered about 1900
threeways and now there's 400 so
something interesting has happened and
there is an equivalent called ICD or
more or less equivalent which is drawn
up by the World Health Organization but
both DSM and ICD are used kind of
internationally now what's very
interesting about the current debate is
that a lot of the strongest criticism is
coming from the world's most powerful
influential psychiatrists some of whom
involved in drawing up these manuals
this is not as perhaps it's sometimes
seen in the 60s the Maverick anti
psychiatrists so-called this is the very
people who drew up these manuals in the
first place so here's a collection of
some of my favorite quotes dr. Alan
Francis chair of the DSM for committee
DSM editions are revised every 10 or 20
years of those so dsm-5 is the fifth
edition you know you're in trouble with
your fifth edition one for your chief
critics is the chair of the DSM for
committee dsm-5 will radically and
recklessly expand the boundaries of
psychiatry there is no reason to believe
that dsm-5
faithful scientifically sound those are
strong words you know I get into trouble
when I see that kind of thing
he's the man who drew it up he should
know for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institutes of arson ideas her III TV
you